is the pandemic good or bad for the
spirits industry liquor stores were
considered an essential business at the
start of the lockdown but at the same
time we saw restaurants and hotels were
shut down decimating sales of alcohol
almost two years into covent now a trend
is emerging this holiday season in which
more americans are opting for no or low
alcoholic beverages
so here now to tell us what he sees in
global spirit consumption is bacardi
executive vice president and chief
financial officer tony latham tony
welcome to quick take
thanks colin how are you good good i
want to go back to my first rhetorical
question to you has the pandemic been
good or bad for your industry
as you mentioned uh you know previous
prior to the pandemic we we represent
about 30 of our revenue from the
on-premise from bars restaurants night
clubs sporting venues uh obviously as
you mentioned that that industry was
decimated by covid so i would say by and
large the pandemic has not been good for
the industry the hospitality industry in
general we did see people switch their
consumption moments from you know from
those on-premise outlets to increasing
their consumption on home but i
certainly wouldn't say it's been good
for us or our industry
got it okay so on the whole it has not
been good but people are changing the
way that they consume their drinks so
let's fast forward to december 2021
because it's the season for a holiday
party so i'm a little surprised to hear
of this trend of no or low alcoholic
beverages taking hold fill us in on how
that's changing the way once again
people are
consuming their drinks
well health and wellness has been a
major trend that's been evolving for a
number of years now it's impacted many
many industries and the alcoholic
beverage industry is no different
people are looking to consume in
moderation we're seeing people consume
better quality more super premium
categories and brands as well but we're
responding to that we're responding to
that with our innovation we're launching
uh multiple uh low alcohol and no
alcohol brands into the marketplace in
fact gregory's essences which i've got
just here is a lower alcohol content
brand and we've launched that in the
last nine to 12 months it's been one of
our most successful innovations so the
key for us is to respond to what the
consumers are asking for
got it got it so how how does that break
down for your sales you mentioned that
people are perhaps opting for more
premium products what does that mean for
your lineup
well we're very happy with the portfolio
that we've got our portfolio skews
towards super premium brands like grey
goose tequila patron angels envy
american whiskey
do say cognac etc so we feel very well
positioned with the trend to super
premium consumption at the moment
what kind of drinks are out of favor as
a result or is there just less
consumption of that as people switch
over for now
as opposed to a permanent shift
i wouldn't call that any one category as
being out of favor at the moment um
again what we're seeing we're seeing
trends towards super premium premium
vodka seems to be back which is great
for our great goose brand
tequila is a very hot category at the
moment cognac and uh all whiskeys are in
hot demand at the moment we've also
introduced a range of ready to drink or
premium prepared cocktails as we prefer
to call them
again which provides the convenience and
portability for consumers across
categories so we're seeing great growth
in our premium prepared cocktails i've
got some bacardi and bombay sapphire
examples here in front of me yeah
meeting consumers where they are right
now
you know as we talk about this trend
towards wellness and people perhaps
opting for low or no alcoholic beverages
we've also seen dry january become a
real thing over the last couple of years
i don't remember it being
something that people talked about
before 2012 or so but really now this is
this idea of abstaining from excesses uh
following all the end of the year uh
celebrations
why do you think this is what do you
think
is so compelling about this idea now
as you mentioned it's been around for
nearly a decade now but certainly
gaining in popularity i think that that
mega trend of uh health and wellness and
people being
more aware of uh of embracing that trend
has certainly been an impact there but
again we're we're looking to um to
capitalize on that by having offerings
that allow people to either enjoy in
moderation during that period or abstain
in in total with some of our no and low
alcohol offerings so we don't think
that's going to be a you know a major
new development this particular year um
distinct from from the recent previous
years yeah just building on this
emerging trend overall all right well
one thing that has become a big issue
over the last two years especially since
the start of covid is supply chain
challenges where do you see the
shortages as most acute
yeah there's a couple of elements to the
supply chain challenges first of all you
know actually getting supply of of
products i have to say that uh our
global supply chain group
has done a phenomenal job in keeping
most of our products in supply
throughout the pandemic uh you know
long-term strategic relationships with
suppliers keeping our factories up and
running etc so that's been a that's been
a good thing for us the other thing of
course that we're seeing is inflation
starting to come through
so we talked a little bit earlier about
how prices are rising for all kinds of
food products and drink products and
bacardi is no exception as well talk a
little bit about the price increases
that you've instituted
over the past year and
the range of increases you've put in
yeah sure so as i mentioned earlier it's
key that you look at pricing through a
strategic lens and
different brands different categories
different markets are impacted very
differently by the inflationary
pressures and so we look at we look at
that through a quite detailed
sophisticated lens to make sure that
we're taking pricing
where our cost base is impacted the most
and where we feel our brands have the
the equity to accommodate that i would
say you know on average we've taken
pricing of around three percent over the
last 12 months and we're constantly
reviewing that again it's very important
to look at that at a category and market
and price tier level
most of the inflation we've seen to date
has largely been on logistics and
distribution we're starting to see
inflation come through on raw materials
and packaging and on labor so we expect
greater inflationary impacts as we head
into our next calendar year and how long
do you wait before you decide to start
raising prices uh because of raw
material costs and because of labor
costs
again it depends on the market depends
on the competitive context the retailer
environment but again we're monitoring
this very very closely and uh where you
know our teams are on the ball and we're
taking pricing when we feel it's um both
necessary and uh and the consumers are
prepared to accept it
got it got it before we go um i do want
to ask you because you're at your drink
station right now what is your number
one recommended cocktail as we get ready
to celebrate the start of another new
year
well it's a great question there's uh
there's a lot of kind of festive
partying going on at the moment um we
feel the gray gut the grey goose martini
is back it's uh it's having a
renaissance moment at the moment um so
martinis made with grey goose are really
flying at the moment and then uh the
angels envy old fashion is another
popular uh drink particularly in the
colder climates so
we're seeing lots of uptake on both
those at the moment great goose martini
and an old fashioned love it thank you
so much for cardi cfo tony latham
joining us here